hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are back at the first
American chess congress and this is Paul
Morphy second game or the first game
according to some sources again it's Jim
James Thomson American chess master here
Morphy has the black pieces and it's a
bit of a different game than we've seen
in game 1 which kind of makes me think
that maybe this is the first game but
it's hard to say I'll let you decide
after you check out the game so Thompson
with the white pieces opens with E for
now we have a 5 point morphine Knight to
f3 Knight to c6 and Bishop to c4 the
Italian game is on the board Bishop to
c5 by morphe now offering Thompson the
opportunity to go for the Evans gambit
but he declines he plays d3 he goes for
the joker pianissimo which is odd as
this is 1857 if someone offers you to go
for the Evans gambit you go for the
Evans gambit but ok Knight to f6 a we
have Knight to c3 and h6 now morphe
realizes that it's it's important to
include this move not allowing this
knight or bishop to have the g5 square
so h6 and now it's it's a position that
that's played even today with the most
common moves Bishop e3 and castles but
here we have Knight to e2 mu that is not
played today all that much but ok it
prepares c3 d4 and you want to start
expanding in the center and now well
morphe could continue with d5 right away
the knight no longer controls the d5
square he goes for d6 instead and c3 now
preparing d4 and here there is a one
notable game played in 2003 in corsica
masters between Arthur Coggan and
Krishnan sickening an Indian Grandmaster
although I don't know if he was a
Grandmaster back then but Bishop to b6
was played here and the white was able
to win that game however the engine
actually prefers amorphous castles to
Bishop to b6 so even though
morphix game was played some 150 years
before this game Murphy actually
continues in the proper way and now this
position has never again been reached so
this is now the only game that follows
this path so we have h3 taking away the
g4 square from Morpheus
and King h8 now here morphe decides that
he wants to play King eh he'll bring the
knight over to h7 so he unpinned and
then he wants to push f5 and start
attacking here with the sniping here
could we could be a bit awkward for
white so King h8 by morphe knight to g3
in the not Knight 2h7 going for this and
going for this f5 idea and this is a
plan that is very often seen but
especially in Indo in those years Queen
to c2 continuing development in the now
f5 and here white already has a problem
his King is still in the center of the
board
amorphous preparing to open up the F
file so here he captures on f5 but now
Murphy gets d5 in and now he has
excellent control of the center and it's
only a temporary pawn sacrifice you can
always pick up the pawn push it back to
b3 and now well well you could continue
with characters captures and captures
Murphy continues doing what he does best
he wants to out calculate his opponent
so efore so what happens here D captures
on e4 we have D captures on e4 and now
here's the question do you capture on e4
or do you not capture on e4 if you align
the Queen and the king on the e-file
rook to e8 could be a bit of a problem
so what would you play here
I feel free to pause the video and try
to find a good way to defend for for
white well I'll give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on calling
morphus bluff and the plain Queen
captures an even four because this is
the strongest move because after Queen
captures rook e8 and now you can block
with Bishop to e6 and now okay you can
start kicking the Queen back Knight f6
Queen goes to c4 for example now
captures pawn captures in the Queen to
d5 forces the Queen trade otherwise rook
captures and e6 is coming and after
captures captures you will recapture the
pawn on the next move and while white
will still be up upon Black is somewhat
up in development and should have some
compensation but it's hard to say how
much white what extra pawn would
definitely matter here so here morphe
kind of bluffed his way with this efore
move
I don't think he he expected Thompson to
calculate everything God properly and I
don't think he considered anyone his
equal when it comes to calculating lines
so Thompson believed him he played
Knight the g1 and this is not all Murphy
needs to start what he what he does best
create a brilliant attack so feel free
to pause the video here and try to find
how Murphy continued the attack here
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on spotting that this
knife belongs on d3 and for those who
just want to enjoy show it's Knight to
e5 now Knights the d3 is unstoppable
there's no way to hide the King to
castle there's no way to add a defender
to the d3 square so here at Thompson
just played Bishop to e3 continued
development but now Knight the d3 with
trick King e2 and now Bishop captures
and e3f captures on e3 and now Queen to
h4 now the knight is under attack and
there's no way to defend the night you
cannot add another defender the pawn
prevents the King from reaching it also
the knight prevents the King from
reaching the f2 square so here at
Thompson did what what he thought was
the only thing left Knight characters on
e4 which makes sense because after Queen
captures you do grab back the piece
after Queen captures on d3 but now just
queen cat person the g2 width Trek King
to d1 and now Bishop captures on f5
attacking the Queen preparing rook a to
d8 here Quinta et was played offering
the Queen trade but now while you can
continue rook a to be 8 more if you just
capture the rook and it was in this
position unmoved 21 that James Thompson
resigned the game and it's a 2 to 0 for
more fee and since it's a 5 game match
if more if he gets one more victory and
then the match is over and he continues
into into the the quarterfinals so here
of course he resigned because you're
down a rook this is the threat this is a
threat the white doesn't really have a
good move so it would be pointless to
continue here so ever nice 21 move
brilliancy which I mean of course if we
go back to this moment after D captures
on e4 and the Morphy offering this Bluff
even if he played if
and played this to perfection which in
those days were very few people could do
against Morphy I'm very sure Murphy
would would win that game being upon
down so he he did give Thompson a chance
Thompson didn't take it so we'll see
what happens in round three and after
that like I said in the previous video
then we are gonna make a short break
from the American chess congress and
we're gonna go to that blindfold game
between Paulson and morphe before
continuing so that's the game I do hope
you enjoy that the game 2 of the
American chess congress between morphe
and thompson i would like to thank Brian
penguin forgot to put a to put a space
there are kids tester Brandon Johnson
Mario and Sinha and crispy card for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check too on my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon
continuing the coverage of the poem or
visa checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and of course whatever else
happens in the chess world so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest your day